I had posted it on Tick Tock and people
were going crazy what an idiot do you
actually think that I jumped off my
house onto a mattress
this didn't look like hits to me no
all of this we did for real going 60
miles an hour so we rode with live Bulls
you'll see us exit and the Bulls were
supposed to stay in and they didn't oh
within two seconds there was just Bulls
like smashing the fence underneath me
wow so what's going on here if something
went wrong we would have both been dead
foreign
huge thanks to Squarespace for
sponsoring today's episode Stick Around
to the end to see how you can get 10 off
your website today hey everybody welcome
back to another amazing episode of stunt
moment react I'm here with two amazing
Solomon I have Kimberly Shannon Murphy
and Amy Johnson is going to be helping
us Host this episode we're so excited to
have her here so I'd love to know how
you got started into stunts and how you
got to where you are now I've been doing
stunts for 18 years I'm still 25. and I
was a professional acrobat before also
danced with the professional program at
Alvin alley got into stunt work in 2003
Dublin Uma Thurman on My Super
Ex-Girlfriend about four or five years
into my career started doubling Cameron
Diaz and she sort of took me in under
her wing and started doubling her and
here I am that's awesome not bad at all
girl
I'm so excited to get into some of your
stuff
I know
we're yellow red gotta Simon how long
did it take to film this whole
motorcycle scene in two months you
mentioned that you did a lot of work
with Tom Cruise my husband doubled him
for 11 years I think pretty much did you
meet him on set we met him
so yeah when you were like
so he did not he didn't do the bike
stunts for Tom Jimmy Roberts did Tom can
ride I did some shots with him on the
bike but all of this turnaround stuff
that we did we did for real going 60
miles an hour we couldn't rehearse it
with helmeton because we had to be so
close to each other when we flipped we
had the bike stationary we sort of
figured out how we were gonna do it and
then we just kind of had to do it and
cross our fingers that it all worked out
like we thought it was going to and we
were also with Bulls so we rode with
live Bulls
so much going on here yeah this was one
of those stunts where if something went
wrong we would have both been dead I was
thinking a padding on yeah obviously
there's no helmets no for me it was kind
of like okay what am I going to put an
elbow pad on if we go down at 60 miles
an hour and elbow pad is not going to
save me were you comfortable on
motorcycles before this I ride I can
ride Jimmy and I just rode really well
together and being on the back is just
being really light and him not feeling
me so I had to just stay really tight
physically so that he didn't feel like I
was throwing his weight off or I was
throwing the bike's weight off you know
your leg is coming around all like the
front controls of the bike he had to
lift his arm off so we did it like that
he had to pick his arm up to let me
around so that's his brake side not his
throttle side but he killed it he's
unbelievable and you don't like kick the
handlebars so many things you're going
60 miles per hour yeah that is crazy
yeah we did it without guns as you could
see it looks like she picks the guns up
if you watch me twist around I don't
have guns in my hand it's also an
engineering problem you have to figure
out how do we make this like mechanical
function of moving my body over here
here without losing balance work I think
the coordinator was we did it probably
on camera three or four times and then
he's like that's it everyone was just
kind of happy to get the shot and just
yeah like moving on that's crazy it
looks so good though like it looks
effortless thank you you did an
incredible job I bet Cameron was so
happy to see also was not happy because
she was like filming another part of the
scene and then when she came and watched
the playback she was like Kimberly you
could have killed yourself
[Music]
close
that's you in the bowls right there yeah
and the Bulls were all real and we
trained with the bulls on a farm before
we did the scene we have a scene in the
beginning of the sequence we're in a
bull riding arena and we were just
supposed to go into in circles with the
bulls and then we were supposed to exit
and these doors were supposed to close
and that was supposed to be it and when
we exited we were at a dead end on the
other side and we weren't on camera
you'll see us exit and the Bulls were
supposed to stay in and they didn't oh
yeah and everybody was Spanish and
everyone's screaming Toro Toro Toro and
I turned around and saw saw the bull and
Jimmy laid the bike down and I climbed
like I didn't I don't even remember
climbing the fence that's how fast I
climbed it within two seconds there was
just Bulls like smashing the fence
underneath me wow yeah and they used the
shot in the movie because I mean it
looks really great
but it wasn't supposed to happen boom
yeah did they change the actual sequence
to like make that the thing they might
have I mean that's obviously ECG the
Bulls didn't really go over the cars
that's insane but yeah it was insane
[Music]
like these trains are real
wow I closed my eyes when we went I was
gonna ask I was like were you having fun
though like yeah so I mean come on it
was so fun yeah obviously there was
always a danger going into anything in
our business when you're doing stunts at
this level but I was with such
professionals the guys drifting the cars
were unbelievable like the top of the
top that we were working with and so it
felt really safe as safe as you can feel
so why not do the train CG it's a really
good question
train rendering technology just wasn't
there yet yeah I mean they could have
done it CG we just didn't probably ask
myself that question later when I
watched it like why didn't we just do
that CG but yeah we didn't and it look
it kind of looks like it could have been
as well so the the motorcycle jump or
this little stairway like when the
motorcycle was flying off the other side
is that you still holding onto the
motorcycle it's a dummy dummy okay I
love dummies in film oh yeah it's such a
like a challenging thing to make it not
look like a dummy yeah and I think they
fix it because she wasn't cute she was
she like flopping around yeah so I um
know your husband and I know that you
guys met on this film I'd love to hear
that love story it was actually really
interesting because the first action
sequence we did was a car chase she's in
the back of the car driving with two
guys the two guys get shot she winds up
reaching over the back seat of the car
and she's driving the car it's really
cool how they did it actually we had two
wheels built on both sides so they could
both drive and for shots where they had
to have their eyes closed closed
captioning
not
available
feel like it's way too stressful to be
in charge of something like that so I
enjoy doing the smaller things like more
you know comedic stuff that is in my
wheelhouse that I feel really
comfortable doing that I'm not worried
about you know killing somebody you know
their jobs are not easy but we do need
more women stunt coordinators so I love
seeing you do that yeah yeah in the
world of studs you have you know you
have all these different types of stunts
you have wire work you have car hits you
have fire burns is there a type of stunt
that you stay away from there's nothing
I haven't done I would say since I had
my daughter there are things like we did
the mech Jeff dashno called me to do it
and in the pilot one of her stunts was a
car hit and when I had my daughter that
was the one thing I said I wasn't going
to do anymore which I actually just did
one last year
um but
but at the time I was like I'm not I
don't want to do a car hit so I did all
the other things and he brought someone
else in to do the car hit just for the
pilot and then I wound up doing insane
things for the whole she had so much and
really like fun quirky things which was
kind of cool everything was just really
different in that show this one being
one of them
[Music]
you okay and then she kind of does a
little small car hit right after it I
had posted it on Tick Tock and people
were going crazy what an idiot I'm like
really do you actually think that I
jumped off my house onto a mattress and
it had like all of these views and Tick
Tock took it down for being this
dangerous thing and I'm like guys you
can see that I'm on a wire because
that's the post that I posted and it
says like Kimberly Shannon Murphy stunts
so clearly hilarious yeah and then what
kind of setup did you have here for the
wire so I had picks on my hips and one
pick on my back I jumped and the picks
on my hips were working so I was on a
dead stop so it stopped me right there
so I couldn't go further and then the
car coming in obviously was separate
what do you think are any misconceptions
of being a stunt woman you know and I'll
get a lot and I'm sure you do too get
like messages on your Instagram like I
really want to get into sense and I'm oh
I always am super try to be really
helpful to people like this is what you
you know you need to do get a minute
reel together even if it's you in the
gym or whatever doing the things that
you do your special skills whatever that
is obviously it's being physically
talented but a lot of it is just working
your ass off really and there is no days
off especially when you're starting in
the business when I started there was
nothing that I said no to because the
more people you work for the more your
name gets around and especially when
you're starting that's what you want so
you're going to be a stunt woman and
call yourself a stunt woman you have to
be willing to and be capable to do all
of the things I mean obviously there are
things like I'm not going to go and jump
a motorcycle it's not my specialty like
there are certain things or horses like
my husband's a Amazing Horse guy you
just can't be really picky you have to
be smart in the sense of never say you
can do something you can't do because
that will get you in trouble and you
will never go anywhere in this business
right nobody wants to work with X and
they don't trust you and you make them
look bad 100
but also like yeah does anyone really
like want to do a car hit yeah or you
want to do a car hit next Nico you know
I wouldn't be opposed to doing a car hit
honestly but we do them really we do
them really
really like the one that we did for
Always Sunny that we had which is
hilarious and you have to listen to her
because she's just so freaking funny
that'll look great when you're in
Ireland
[Applause]
oh [ __ ] so we do them a lot smarter now
and some people will still do them old
school old school but it does they don't
need to be done that way anymore we had
a big green screen at the car drove
through the green screen behind it I did
the pull without the car I just did the
ratchet so that was the ratchet and then
I got on the hood of the car we were
trying to break the windshield but it
wasn't working so I got on the hood of
the car and he just drove into it and
stopped at a dead stop and I just went
off the car they never showed the
landing which is a bummer because we did
it a ton of times and we had a camera
really low that got the landing but we
never did it so I never you know
technically got hit by the car I did the
ratchet I got on top of the car I went
off the car and that's how we did it do
you think it looks different or looks
better to the audience of doing it one
way or the other no and I don't think
it's necessary because a lot of times
they'll cut into I mean on this one they
didn't but a lot of times they'll cut
into the actor they're on the hood for a
second and shooting through the
windshield and they see the actor and
then they go flying off you know so it's
cut up anyway so to do it for real I
don't know you just never know where
you're gonna land is the problem I just
feel like safety wise if you don't have
to do it yes you shouldn't do it
everybody we look at clips that are
suggestions from you know from all of
you watching Kimberly is a type of stunt
that you would like to see on this show
it would be interesting to see car hits
broken down ones that are actually full
car hits and ones that are not full car
hits meaning in the sense of done with
green screen and done intakes and to see
what actually looks better and to see if
it's really worth us getting hit by cars
for real anymore perfect so please leave
a comment down below with awesome car
hit scenes for us to check out in
another episode someone set me up
foreign what did you think of atomic
blonde I thought it was great yeah I
always love a good woman ass kicker and
Charlize she's very good I will say I
mean I don't know I didn't obviously
didn't do the movie so I have no idea
what she did or didn't do but at least
when I was training with her for Old
Guard she wanted to do everything she
was rehearsing everything she was
throwing the guys around she was
learning the choreography and you can
see her on the shot of many of these and
she has like really nice intention in
her movements and she's going through
yeah of this stuff yeah it helps when
the actress can you know do a lot of the
movements and you get that time to train
them
this didn't look like hits to me no at
all yeah so bad about that for me I'm
like just put a pad on and unless it's
the unless she was doing it with yeah
she was probably doing it with the actor
that's probably why oh no his face is
hidden so it's the double so you hit him
if you're gonna shoot it from that angle
it's like that yeah you know otherwise
you're gonna flip around and then you
won't be able to tell as much if she's
hitting him or not but you could tell
that she was just like yeah doing that
like her punches are great but the
impact is it's barely there you don't
even see his jacket moves I pretty much
have a rule when it comes to
choreography and when I'm doing fight
scenes No knees to the gut no hands to
the gut because for the most part
everything just gets hidden and covered
up and you can't sell the hit like you
know being able to whip your head with
your hair flying like that sells a hit
but like it's really hard to sell that
well it depends how you shoot it though
it's all about like where the camera is
because you can do really good knee
strikes that sell really well if you do
them really well or if you do like a
flying knee to the gut and the person's
upright then that can look nice or even
an under shot of like a knee to the
chest yeah but yeah most the time it
does look kind of like old school yeah
yeah something's really good then I'll
you know whatever I'll let them do
everything they want to do so then what
did you said you worked on Old Guard in
this movie she was 6 000 years old so
she knew every fight technique which was
for me really challenging because like
here's your sword and your Hatchet and
your gun and your you know all of the
things and
so these close-up shots it's like on a
platform and they're like doing their
thing we have them on a toe rig they
basically built this rig that drove and
then they attached the bike to it so
then they could just put the cameras and
then they could shoot them as the it's
driving so they're not actually riding
the motorcycle I'm not mistaken this is
top gun Maverick on your IMDb I do did
previous for it for the football scene
our neighbor is Matt Moore Casey brought
him in to choreograph the football scene
for Top Gun does your daughter ever get
jealous like Mom I want to jump off of a
rooftop she only cares about like Taylor
Swift well you double Taylor Swift There
You Go have you seen Taylor on the
treadmill yeah Taylor on the treadmill
we did have her on wires running then
she would just tip forward and then
everything else was me have you two ever
worked together boss [ __ ] fight
challenge that actually Zoe Bell put
together and Cameron I think it was the
first thing she filmed since 2010.
[Music]
foreign
is there anything more compelling than
these incredible stunt women sitting
down with Nico and breaking down the
magic of how they do what they do maybe
actually
you know what I thought of one today's
sponsor Squarespace that's right if you
are interested in making an incredible
captivating beautiful website for
yourself or your small business
Squarespace has the tools that you're
going to need to get the job done so
here's what they do first and foremost
they offer beautiful award-winning
templates with 24 7 customer service
that allow you to get started building
your own website today not yesterday not
tomorrow today right now they do this
without you needing to know anything
about website coding or design well you
might need to know a little bit about
design but that's on you okay pal but
Jake how can it get any better than the
things you just said well I'll tell you
how Squarespace has members only areas
that allow you to create exclusive
content for your product or service
directly on your Squarespace website
that already exists isn't that wonderful
but that's not all Squarespace has top
analytics which means that you can
understand who's coming to your website
what they're doing and allow you to
better tailor your website to the people
people that are coming to it in addition
to that they have audio blocks and video
blocks which mean that you can embed
your audio and video as it's out on the
internet onto your site so people don't
have to go off to your podcast or to
your YouTube channel or to your Tick
Tock look I don't know what people are
doing these days everybody's an
influencer but guess what now you can
put all that in one place and manage it
all from one place and give people the
experience all in one place so if you're
interested in getting all of this
started today head on over to
squarespace.com corridorcrew you will
get 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain that's squarespace.com
corridorcrew once again huge thanks to
them for always sponsoring this show now
let's get back to the show I'm sad I'm
sad that this episode's coming to an end
I can't believe you've been a really
awesome guess yeah really awesome
co-host oh my gosh everyone's trying to
be like
for all you out here if you'd like to
follow more of Kimberly's work you can
follow her Instagram at Kimberly Shannon
Murphy stunts you can also check out our
Tick Tock but there's a bunch of really
awesome behind the scenes footage on
your Instagram and feel free to follow
me and DM me and all those things but
thank you so much for being thank you
for having me it's an absolute pleasure
super fun and to all of you I'm keeping
this simple please consider subscribing